as more coronavirus cases are discovered
in the US the death toll is rising as
well six people have died so far all of
them in Washington State and there are
now at least 102 cases across 15
different states including new ones in
New Hampshire and Georgia one infected
man passed through Atlanta's Airport on
his way back from Italy health officials
are especially concerned today about a
cluster of infections at a nursing home
in Kirkland that's a suburb of Seattle
and where we find Jonathan Vigliotti
Jonathan good morning what are you
hearing about conditions there in the
nursing home good morning to you Tony
first I just want to point out you see
an ambulance leaving here they arrived
here a short while ago taking one
patient to the hospital for testing
listen we've been speaking with family
members who have loved ones inside who
are in isolation many of them showing
all of the symptoms and yet not being
taken to the hospital for testing state
health officials say they simply do not
have all of the options available to
them right now as their resources are
stretched and they say they have to wait
until cases like this one we just saw
turn critical the corona virus outbreak
at a Washington State nursing home is
pushing officials to intensify the
response to contain the disease we
expect the number of cases will continue
to increase in the coming days and weeks
here in King County officials are
planning to buy a motel and set up
modular units to house coronavirus
patients requiring isolation they are
most concerned about the elderly like
those at the Life Care Center nursing
home I'm anxious very anxious
Carmen graves mother Susan Haley is
under quarantine at the facility you
asked for your mother to be tested for
corona virus what did they tell you that
she did not meet the criteria at this
time they're being held hostage in a
petri dish in San Antonio Texas
the mayor is declaring a public health
emergency after a woman who tested
positive for corona virus was initially
cleared and then visited this mall
before all of her results came back as
mayor of the city I find it totally
unacceptable that CDC would release a
patient prior to receiving all test
results and potentially exposed to the
public to this harm the city also filed
a temporary restraining order against
the government to keep more than one
20 passengers from the diamond princes
cruise ship quarantined longer than the
two weeks required more than 700 people
on board were infected with the virus
Monday President Trump met with
executives of ten pharmaceutical
companies to discuss developing a
vaccine which officials say is at least
a year away we're also moving with
maximum speed to develop therapies so
that we can help people recover as
quickly as possible and President Trump
says he hopes to have up to a million
people tested by the end of this week
Anthony Jonathan thank you